welcome back so we've been walking
through this document roadmap 2030 on
how control will be Central in solving
some of the world's most pressing
societal challenges in the coming years
and decades and today I'm going to zoom
in on one of my favorite chapters
chapter 7 on ethics fairness and
Regulatory issues
this is a continuing threat actually
through all of these chapters but really
culminating in chapter seven which is
not just seeing control theory as a
mathematical infrastructure for you know
controlling a dynamical system but
really understanding that when we use
control to address societal scale
challenges there absolutely is a human
element and we need to look at our
control theory Solutions through this
this societal lens through the lens of
how this impacts human beings and so
that's one of the things I really really
like about about this uh this chapter
here is this idea that there is a kind
of higher level optimization if you will
so control theory in my mind you are
kind of optimizing a controller to
achieve some objective subject to the
constraints of the Dynamics of your
system to the rules of your system
but again when we think about this at a
societal level there are other you know
costs and uh and objectives than just
stabilizing a system or just reducing
greenhouse gas emission or whatever the
objective may be we might just not want
to just decrease greenhouse gas
emissions or make our power grid more uh
more resilient and more stable but we
might want to do so in a way that is
Equitable where the benefits of this are
you know seen by by everybody by diverse
groups and not just a small subset of
the population okay that's something we
might want to explicitly optimize over
and that's the kind of thing that we
think about here is what are the ethical
and equity and fairness aspects of these
various societal scale control
uh Solutions whether it is autonomy or
self-driving cars or the sharing economy
or you know things like uber and Airbnb
how do we develop these infrastructures
so that it benefits people broadly and
not you know again a small subset of
people that's a really really important
thing again when we think about societal
challenges is to think about this
through the lens of society Society is
formed of humans how do we make sure
that these Technologies are
um you know good for people's mental and
physical health how do we make sure that
the decisions that are being made are
transparent and uh you know really clear
so that people can actually have
discussions on the ethics without there
being this this uh convoluted opacity of
how these control decisions are being
made I think that's really really
important
um and again this is applicable to
everything we've talked about before in
every domain whether it's an emerging
technology in machine learning for
control and Big Data whether it is is
you know the electrification of the
power you know the electrification of
all of our devices and the resilience of
the power grid whether it's autonomy
self-driving cars robotics you name it
there are absolutely ethics Equity
fairness and Regulatory issues that we
need to be thinking about and we can't
just think about those as something
after we develop our control solution
now we get to think about the ethics of
it it really should be on the design
stage in the in the drawing board okay I
actually think it's kind of interesting
control theorists
in in the past you know decades past
often were brought in after a system was
designed let's say you designed an
aircraft and you designed an engine and
you put everything together and it
doesn't quite work the way you wanted it
to that's when you know 30 years ago you
would call your control engineer and
have them come try to fix it so control
theory was like a Band-Aid on a
pre-designed system now in the modern
era we're kind of smart enough to know
the control theory should be in the room
at the design stage when the you know
the actual design optimization is
happening on the drawing board you need
control theorists there to say what's
possible and what's not possible and
things like that
similarly I think you know we can't
think of ethics and fairness and
Regulatory issues as something we do
after we design a solution they have to
be in that design process okay it's kind
of obvious when you say it this chapter
makes it very clear and gives lots of
good examples and recommendations for
how we can think about this from a
societal lens
um and one of the uh examples that um
and this is you know there's some cool
pictures uh you know autonomy is not
just going to be self-driving cars it's
going to be a three-dimensional Urban
Air Mobility
um presumably we'll have you know the
ability to move goods and services in
the air and on ground this is going to
have safety issues and privacy issues
all kinds of issues but it's also going
to solve some real problems and that's
how technology always is you have uh
anytime you you have a new capability
you also have new issues associated with
it we need to address those head on
one of the examples I think is really
kind of Illuminating and kind of helped
me think about this
is this idea of so-called energy justice
so we are trying to make our power grid
more renewable and cleaner more solar
more wind this is going to address you
know big societal issues like climate
change also resiliency and redundancy
and things like that there's good
reasons to do this for for lots of
reasons
but we want to make it so that the
benefits of a clean power grid and you
know clean air and clean uh a clean
Society are something that everybody
experiences and benefits from so you
know currently to install solar panels
on your house it's pretty expensive even
with subsidies and so that is you know
in many places in the world a luxury
that you know only a certain uh you need
a certain amount of wealth to be able to
afford those solar panels to be able to
afford to contribute to that clean uh
power grid and so we really need to be
thinking through you know in our
optimization problem how do we make sure
that we're optimizing for a large
distributed societal benefit and and
societal
um kind of gains from these new
technologies that has obviously issues
and benefits for societal stability and
health and you know there's long-term
benefits that we really need to be
optimizing over by not having these
Solutions only benefit you know the
wealthiest people that can afford them
okay really important things for us to
be thinking about and I always think
about this when I tell my students you
know control theory is an optimization
problem machine learning is an
optimization problem most of engineering
is an optimization problem
if you neglect to add terms in your
optimization that quantify things you
care about like you know health and
stability and things like that if you if
you if you fail to include the human
element in your optimization you are in
fact making a choice of what you're
optimizing over and that's just
something we need to be thinking about
more generally is you know these
mathematical optimizations there are
human costs and human benefits and we
need to be thinking about optimizing
those as well and you can think about a
lot of those systems as actual dynamical
systems and control systems it's not
always you know there's ethical gray
areas how do you optimize the control of
a disease when there's people's lives at
stake it's it's a murky messy problem
but I think we owe it to ourselves to
address it head on as engineers and as
problem solvers and actually include
those terms in our cost functions we
know you know economics does this and
there is probably some benefit of
bringing control theory into those
discussions okay a huge huge topic you
know I can't do it justice please go
read about it read about it throughout
all of these chapters but again
something I really really like about
this document is that it is not just
kind of numerical or theoretical
solutions to these problems it really
thinks about control theory and its
impacts from a societal lens as well
which I think is super important all
right thank you